il a faim que savons nous ce matin de
cette attaque et où on l enquête
oui alors le suspect on le sait
maintenant est un homme d'origine
soudanaise âgé de 33 ans il a obtenu le
statut de réfugié en 2010 est ainsi
qu'un titre de séjour de 10 ans en
juillet de la même année
alors il est inconnu des services de
police et des renseignements français il
vivait dans le centre ville de romans
sur isère il a été interpellé sans
résistance très rapidement après les
faits par l'une des patrouilles de
police chargés de faire respecter le
confinement alors selon les enquêteurs
et plusieurs témoins qui étaient sur
place l'assaillant était à genoux sur un
trottoir en train de prier en arabe lors
de son interpellation il a été placé en
garde à vue samedi soir tout comme une
de ses connaissances alors concernant l'
enquête le parquet antiterroriste a
ouvert une enquête pour assassinat en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
et association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels
les premiers éléments mettent en
évidence un parcours meurtrier de nature
à troubler l'ordre public par
l'intimidation ou la terreur le parti et
le parquet anti terroriste indique
également que lors d'une perquisition au
domicile de l'assaillant les documents
manuscrits à connotation religieuse dans
lesquels l'auteur se plaint de vivre
dans un pays de mes crayons ont été
retrouvés et enfin comme vous l'avez dit
au niveau des victimes
on rappelle qu'il y à deux personnes qui
ont été tuées deux hommes âgés de 44 et
55 ans et cinq blessés du côté du
gouvernement samedi dans l'après midi le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui était présent sur les lieux
avait déjà évoqué le parcours
terroristes du suspect et enfin le chef
de l'état emmanuel macron a qualifié
l'attaqué d' acte odieux qui vient
endeuiller notre pays déjà éprouvé ces
dernières semaines merci les la femme
ouzou pour ces précisions